hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast the dynamics of beta amyloid
plaque genesis an in vivo study in
transgenic mice of Alzheimer's disease I
am Julia Oracle a brutes and all be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar being part of the search
theory presented by lab roots and
sponsored by big plane the world's
leading 3d interactive microscopy image
analysis software company in the search
webinar series will invite researchers
from the top scientific and medical
institutions who have dedicated their
work to discover new therapeutic agents
or vaccines for some of the most severe
diseases of the 21st century we are
delighted to discover that in many cases
maras the plane and the new technology
is implemented in on doors system and
cameras have pushed the research forward
putting the scientists closer to
complaining new therapy for more
information please visit bit plane calm
/ search we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we will try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or that your
problem through the green Q&A button
lower left I would now like to introduce
today's speakers stefan Burkle's is a
postdoctoral researcher with a strong
focus on imaging technology and its
applications at the department for
translational brain research professor
dr. Johan Thames of the German center
for neurodegenerative diseases easy and
eight in unix germany in peters is a
german biochemist with strong focus on
neuroscience and neurodegenerative
diseases he received his education at
the university of hamburg the pelvis did
toil univer
city and the Free University of Berlin I
will now turn it over to skin tears for
his presentation okay thank you very
much for your kind introduction and
welcome everybody to this webinar so the
two of us we are working in the lab of
young house in Minich and the lab is
focused on ethanol research and today we
will show you how to measure the
dynamics of beta amyloid plaque genesis
and in this regard we will first give a
short introduction to add sinus disease
for those who are not so familiar with
the topic and then the main part will be
about the methodology that we apply
including in vivo two-photon microscopy
and detailed image analysis and then we
will show the results and finally we
will come to an outlaw how these
findings can be used to test therapeutic
strategies and what are important
considerations during the planning of
such experiments okay and so the asanas
disease is a devastating disorder
affecting approximately 44 million
people worldwide the first clinical
symptom that autumn her patients
experience is the loss of episodic
memory and it is exactly this slowly
progressing loss of memories making
autumns disease a tragic disorder when
we lose our memories we lose our
personality and this is similar like
losing our face of course it is not only
a terrifying experience for the
patient's themselves but also for their
relatives in addition the disease
imposes the tremendous economic burden
on the society to date no cure is
available that can halt or at least slow
down this degradation therefore current
therapies are restricted only to
symptomatic treatment and caregiving
however new promising drugs targets have
been found in our own investigation so
and when we now have a look at the brain
of an optimal patient we can observe a
severe atrophy of tissue as you see in
this image
lots of brain systems is caused by a
loss of neurons and their synapses and
this is thought to cause the loss of
cognitive functions here on the right
image we've seen historical brain
section from the first item of patient
or goes to data and in this image we can
nicely see the two microscopic hallmarks
of this disease first here on the right
amyloid plaques and then on the left
neurofibrillary tangles and the main
component of amyloid plaques was found
to be the amyloid beta peptide or also
shortly a better it is derived by
sequential cleavage of the amyloid
precursor protein a PP now the colors
and the sequence of events leading to
the azimuth disease were postulated in
the amyloid cascade hypothesis it starts
with the aberrant metabolism of ATP
leading to the formation of an amyloid
beta peptide is prone to aggregate and
this aggregation is thought to initiate
the deadly cascade here you see a better
monomer and this one can now form
oligomers pro football's amyloid fibrils
and finally large microscopic clocks as
next step in this cascade we observe
progressive synaptic and neuronal
injuries and this is followed by
widespread your own dysfunction and cell
death and at the very end of the cascade
we diagnose altima dementia so for our
study we use the TG 2576 mouse model of
arsenal disease which is based on the
amyloid cascade hypothesis we just
explained to you this muslin was
developed in the lab of Greg Cole and
expresses a human ATP with the Swedish
mutation a better is released from a PP
by sequential enzymatic cleavage first
by the better secretase and then by the
gamma secretase and the Swedish mutation
harvest an exchange of two amino acids
at the better secretase cleavage site
and results in increased production of
you
narrator in this mouse model the
synaptic injuries start as early as
three months of age as you see here and
this is followed by first cognitive
deficits at eight six months of age and
finally Ethel amyloid pathology starts
at nine months of age and in this models
line progresses relatively slowly so um
when we want to measure a therapeutic
effect on amyloid plaque growth we face
the problem of broad plug size
distributions in the picture above we
see an example of a plaque that was
imaged ex vivo in a brain section of a
TG 2576 mouse in the charge on the Left
we see the sizes of clarks measured at
12 months of age it is obvious from this
chart that there are much more smaller
than larger plugs when we have a look at
the size distributions of clarks and the
second chart this becomes even more
obvious so the plaque sizes at the given
age are scattered over the quite large
range of sizes and yeah you can see this
year and when you know it transforms
data to lower ethnic scale we can nicely
fit the gaussian curve to this data thus
the plug size is log normally
distributed which is in line with
findings in humans with the Alzheimer's
disease in 18 month old mice the plaque
sizes are shifted towards larger values
as you see here in the blue line however
there is still a big overlap between
both distributions and of course it
would be possible to measure this small
difference with a single time point
analysis using ex vivo data but when we
want to evaluate a therapeutic effect
with small difference and there's this
small difference that you see here
refers to the hundred percent control
value and therefore it is almost
impossible to detect moderate
therapeutic effects in the range of
twenty to forty percent because the
shift in size that you have to measure
would simply be too small now to
increase the statistical power we image
the same population of plaques many
times over several month to obtain
kinetic measurements of individual plugs
and for this we applied in vivo
two-photon microscopy a technique that
we would like to introduce in the next
slide okay here on the upper left you
will see a typical 24 microscope and our
lab with an anesthetized Mouse already
placed underneath and the nonlinear
effect of two-photon excitation takes
place when two photons coincide on a
fluorescent molecule these photons must
have twice the wavelength or in other
words half the energy that is necessary
for the excitation by a single photon
shown here in these two long she
diagrams at normal light intensities
two-photon excitation is very unlikely
to take place to to get an impression of
this almost impossible event I want to
tell you a short comparison by venturi
tank and kettle vago de who are two
pioneers of this technique so imagine a
sunny day when all of us would wear
sunglasses with a good one with the with
a good one or two foreigners robot on
this sunny day around one photon per
second is absorbed via a 1 photon robber
and whereas only one photon per 10
million years would be absorbed via a
two-photon event and but when you have
the use of when you use a pulse laser
and with a high power and focus the
laser beam we obtain measurable
fluorescent excitation that is
restricted to the focal spot moreover we
get intrinsic optical sectioning within
the set direction in contrast to one
photon excitation where the whole light
cone is excited and in these two
pictures and it's very nicely
illustrated the effect here these are
two thrusting filled cadets and in the
case of single-photon excitation
the whole laser beam is visible as you
see on the right whereas on a two-photon
excitation the fluorescence is
restricted to a single focal spot so the
main advantages here over conventional
laser scanning microscopy our first the
much greater penetration depth of over
eight hundred micrometers into brain
tissue then intrinsic optical sectioning
and also a reduction in phototoxicity to
scanning in XY direction in this
microscope and automated movement in
that direction we obtain a
point-by-point 3d data set for each
detection channel and this this data set
can then we reconstruct it and can be
displayed as a 3d volume rendered image
as you see here on the upper right in
green color we see neurites labeled with
a yellow fluorescent protein in the
mouse cortex and in blue we see amyloid
plaques stained with small molecule
fluorescent dye called Botox EXO for now
to gain direct optical access to the
brain we used an open skull cranial
window preparation that you see here on
the left for the window implementation a
small piece of skull of about four to
five millimeters in diameter is removed
and replaced by a Glen by a glass window
this glass coverslip is glued to the
skull with dental cement and as you see
it very well in this image a small metal
bar is glued right next to it and this
match this metal bar is so this is used
to easily fixate the anesthetized mouse
under the microscope and without any
rotational artifacts and through this
glass window we can now see the brain
and the state blood was the pattern that
we see here is very useful for us to
price precisely relocate the image
positions from one imaging session to
another the third image here shows the
image portion that is visible in the
wide field mode of the microscope and
finally a rectangular chunk of brain
tissue can be recorded via laser
scanning and
in this example we see the signal again
from amyloid plaques stand with me toxic
so for this junk has an approximate size
of half a millimeter in equal X Y and
0.3 millimeters in depth while the
unique blood vessel pattern of the brain
surface that you see in the second image
on the left is used for raft
repositioning we use the positions of
these labeled Clarke's the TC on the
right for fine-tuned alignments thus we
can record the amyloid pathology at it
precisely defined location repeatedly
over a long period of time so and in the
next slide want to show you an example
of an amyloid plaque growth kinetics the
movie will see the timeless movie that
was acquired over a period of more than
one year here you see the first time on
of the image series that was acquired by
an evil two-photon microscopy to stay in
a minute flax and evil we use the
fluorescence small molecule die methoxy
x0 for this diet was developed in the
lab of william Clank it passes the
blood-brain barrier and specifically
binds to the beta sheet structure of the
Crippler amyloid beta species the
spatial dimensions of the 3d stack r850
x 850 micrometer in XY plane and 350
micrometer in depth from the brain
surface in the beginning we see four
plaques and the 3d volume rendered image
starting the time series we can observe
that new flex develop and that all
blacks probe over time this few seconds
lasting time-lapse movie was acquired
over a period of 15 months and reality
imaging was done and weekly intervals
you
in addition we can detect the
development of a typical cerebral
amyloid angiopathy these long structures
are composed of aggregated protein that
covers the blood vessel wall
you
so after completing the acquisition of
our time-lapse movie and now we want to
perform a quantitative analysis of the
image data we be obtained and so to
track the precise volume of single
amyloid plaques over time 3d surface
rendering is performed choosing amaris
the software for 3-d and 4-d analysis
and in the next movie want to show you
how we perform the analysis practically
photo 3d data analysis we use in Mars
but you could use any other software
capable of doing a 3d surface raineri
here you see the software and at the
center the image data is displayed in
two dimensions and here we have our
timeline and on the left we can scroll
through the image step start and the
doctor colors constitute the background
not here and with the darkest portions
representing flat vessels so like the
structures here so nice DC and the right
parts show the signal from the admin
flats so these are this year now we can
also switch to the 3d mode of the
software and here we see the freaky
volume rendered image and we can change
the display settings for example here
one word to hide the background to
better see our other flags and you can
easily rotate the image and watch our
image volume from the side
you can go back to the top view and
there are also different rendering modes
so we can use this blend mode for
example or also this nominating mode and
we have already loaded time serious into
Lamar's and we can watch here the time
lapse next we want to perform the
surface rendering to extract the volumes
of single flags over time to do this we
use the surface function mouse and click
here and this research comes up and
guides us through the analysis so we
uncheck segment region of interest on
your region of interest and we keep
check services overtime enabled then you
click Next and we use only one channel
that we use we keep the smoothing option
enabled and we use the background
subtraction as the thresholding method
and here we enter the diameter of the
largest flag which is around 25 of
micrometer in this case now we click
Next and the computer is calculating
surfaces which takes some time
so the calculation is now finished and
we already see our surfaces for this
threshold here and we change the
threshold to 500 and this threshold will
automatically use for all time points
and this analysis and now we want to
calculate the surfaces the surface
rendering itself is finished now and we
can uncheck here to imaging borrow one
and we keep our surfaces here and in a
next step you can apply filters and to
classify specific objects and one
problem in the analysis is the presence
of small autofluorescence structures in
brain tissue and that are also detected
in the same emission chamber as the
macaque see signal from the flax and we
characterize these Auto fluorescent
structures and they are usually very
small like for example these ones and
they are not stable over time so you see
there are some points that are coming up
form time point and then go right next
and you want to exclude them from the
analysis or change analysis and care for
me consider two filtering steps and 1st
we apply a filter to include objects
only larger than 10 micrometers so
therefore we change this river here to
volume which is royal and we have
already are 10 micrometer threshold here
and now 402 out of 548 objects are
selected
now we click Next and open this result
field we could manually process the
detected surfaces but we will skip 27
doing our analysis and now we come to
the tracking tab and here we use the
ibuprofen Brownian motion to track our
flags over time as parameters we use 20
micrometers maximum distance and use as
maximum gap size zero and now we click
Next and the computer is calculating so
now we see our tracks here on the swing
but not our surfaces so therefore I go
to the Settings tab and choose your
surface eyes or face and we see them
again and at the stage you put also
apply a filter to the tracking results
for he will skip this step by now
therefore we delete this filter and
finish our tracking and for analysis
wizard now we can inspect the protective
tracks and as an example we will select
the spec thick black here and first
before we can select it we have to go to
the tractor and now it is selected and
on the left side we see here the
complete tracks and durrett check this
refers to the selected flag of course
and now here we have our time for ants
or different time points and we see
however and the last time I'm point is
not correctly detected and into
is jacking and the reason for it is
incomplete tracking is in perfect
alignment of the different time lines
and we can clearly see this when you
watch the time that's moving or two
surfaces see how the trip between the
time forms and therefore we will use
free correctly detected tracks that were
the complete duration and to align the
time that's moving over time so in there
forever choose for example this one here
it goes over the configuration and we
add this one it's also present in for a
10 points and the third one MVC or three
are present at all time points and now
we press this correct drift button here
so your forethought appears and as I
definitely use translational and
rotational trip and the resulting data
set size should be cropped to the
largest common regions so now we press
ok and we'll correct our time-lapse
movie so do you tooth correction is
completed by now and when we watch the
time-lapse movie again we can clearly
see that alignment is much better over
time than before and with this optimized
alignment of our objects here we will
perform the tracking again that were we
go here to this we build tab and we
choose as a gryphon only to track in
and we click on the rebuild fun so we
have already around algorithm stated
here thrown in motion and parameters
will also take again as before and click
next and now calculate and it's finished
and we finish the tracking and now we go
back again to the tracking tab and
select our big flag from the analysis
for and we see that the track is now
completed over to complete duration of a
time points let's come to the last step
of our analysis as mentioned before one
important criterion to separate
autofluorescence from Hamlet flexes the
stability of time and we consider the
objects as blacks when they are present
for at least three time points in a row
and when they are present until the last
time point and therefore you apply
another filter so first you have to go
here to the Striga tab that we can apply
to our objects and we click the add
button and the first third of your eye
will be and time index filter so we
choose this from this menu and
go to the time index so now we have
children us and we adjust our range that
pony tracks are detected or selected
that have an object at the last time
point we duplicate our selection to a
new surface so we have to you know here
and from this sub selection we again
filter for track duration so excluding
tracks that are shorter than three time
points therefore we go again to the
further tap add a filter and choose
track duration here and now we just
arrange that only tracks are detected
that are present for at least three time
points this is like this in this case
and we duplicate our selection again to
in your surface and
now you can see our result of the
analysis and let me go back to the track
tab we see that we have only flags that
are present at the last time point and
we have flags that are present for the
whole imaging period and we have new
appearing flags that come up during the
imaging duration and that's random time
absolutely again and now we see this
unstable atoms on the way finally we can
go to the statistics tab so because we
of course we want to have in our numbers
from there from the analysis and what we
are interested in is of course the
volume over time therefore we go here to
this sophisticated and choose detailed
and you can choose from these specific
values the volume of our objects and to
export them we can click here on this
disk and the menu is popping up and we
can save our file and our analysis is
finished so our image analysis is
finished now and we get an axial sheet
with all our numbers and here we plot
the volume of a single plaque into a
graph and unfortunately there is a
problem with displaying the chart so on
the x-axis you would see the age and
mums ranging from 12 to 23 months and on
the y-axis we see the volume from zero
to sixty thousand cubic micrometer
fortunately we still see most of the
values and to this data a cubic function
can be nicely fitted and please note
that very high regression coefficient
which indicates an almost perfect sit
from the volume we calculate the clock
radio assuming a sick shape of the
amyloid plaques and we see that the
increase in radius follows a linear
function and correspondingly we can also
perform a linear regression and the
slope of this line corresponds to the
linear growth rate of the Emerald class
this linearization was developed in the
lap of materials yukl and tubing Germany
this linear growth rate means that in
our example a layer of beta-amyloid with
a thickness of about half a micrometer
is deposited every week and this is
similar to the annual rings of a tree
but of course these are added every year
to complete the list of quantitative
parameters the plug density was also
analyzed now let's have a look at the
complete data from the movie we watched
before in this graph we see the mean
volume of all plaques imaged over time
with the ninety-five percent confidence
intervals starting at 12 months of age
to this data a sigmoid function can be
nicely fitted which reflects the early
and strong cubic growth phase and the
late saturation phase of black roof in
contrast the plug density kinetics show
an asymptotic progression reaching a
plateau when we have a look on the
volume kinetics of all individual
plaques from this experiment we see the
great variability between the growth
kinetics again you can observe
that only a few plaques become very big
whereas the majority is mid to
small-sized with this long-term imaging
study well 15 months we were able to
show for the first time a complete black
roof kinetics in an item a mouse model
showing both the cubic as well as a
saturation face interestingly when we
compare the kinetics to in vitro studies
we see the same sigmoid growth curve but
over a shorter duration of of days to
weeks importantly a biomarker study in
Ultima patients utilizing PET imaging in
combination with the amulet binding
agent Pittsburgh compound B also show a
similar trend of a beaded deposition
here the time frame of the position
until saturation takes about 20 years
interestingly the clinical symptoms on
that which is the Reverend point 0 on
the x-axis coincides with this time
point of saturation from all these
observations we can conclude that
amyloid plaques grow continuously over
time until black Grove tapers off at
older ages well in the emerging over 15
months is very difficult to perform of
course and in order to get data from her
higher number of miles we compared the
black Grove kinetics between a young and
old cord of miles between 12 and 14 and
18 and 20 months we chose the age
cohorts in a way that they reflect the
cubic and the saturation phase of black
Grove in the ankle world the mean flux
density shown on the y-axis increased
over the observation period of two
months to too many newly formed flags
during this period plugged entity was
even higher in the World Court but at
this age no newly formed plaques were
observed and therefore we don't see a
further increase in plug density between
18 and 20 months we can conclude that
the plug density increases strongly with
age and reaches a plateau these
observations correspond again to the
plug density kinetics of the long-term
imaging experiment plug size
measurements calculated as min clock
radios also showed an increase with
aging this letter suggests that the flux
flux grow over time as expected the
smaller size category where the newly
formed plaques the left column and in
the old cohort there is still a very
small increase in the mean black size
over the two-month observation period so
at 18 and 20 months on the right the to
write columns but this difference is not
statistically significant next we
compared the median clock growth rate of
the newly formed and the pre-existing
plaques and the medium black growth
rates were not different in the young
cohort of mice so forth between the
newly formed and pre-existing plaques
however the meeting krakoff rates are
significantly higher than zero leading
to the conclusion that plaques grow
continuously over time in contrast the
medium black growth rate showed a
significant decrease in the old cohort
with over with a median value still
above zero the fact that we can still
detect a significant growth in the old
cohort with our kinetic parameter proves
that this parameter is more sensitive in
comparison to sympathize measurements at
single time points
this regard please remember that in the
old cohort we could not attack the
difference and plaque radius what I've
shown you and is like before so now
let's come back to our growth model and
in the younger cohort a layer of
constant thickness is added every week
similar to the three rings what we see
here in this picture at older ages the
thickness of the Rings decreases in the
case of the tree may be due to a lack in
nutrients in the case of black roof the
ever increasing surface of amyloid
plaques need an ever-increasing amount
of a pita to keep a constant thickness
of each layer that is added every week
in the old court the amount of a biga
needed to keep the growth rate of the
young cohort might exceed this the
amount that is actually produced and
therefore the thickness of the layer is
added every week is smaller than the
neon accord this is similar to the leg
and nutrients in the case of the tree
which led to thinner annual rings at
later ages or older ages on this last
slide we want to summarize important
considerations to investigate the
therapeutic efficacy of new tracks the
target the amulet pathology first a huge
number of different Ultima mouse models
are available each model has different
black roof genetics and a different
onset of amyloid pathology therefore it
is important to choose the correct age
for imaging amyloid plaque growth
kinetics another important issue is the
therapeutic strategy that needs to be
tested if it aims at preventing amyloid
formation and growth the ideal growth
phase would be the dynamic cubic phase
what we see here in this illustration in
this regard the most interesting
parameters would be the Black Rose
plug density kinetics which reflects the
plaque formation if the therapeutic
strategy aims at targeting existing
amyloid plaques the ideal growth rate
would be the saturation or late cubic
phase and a lot of amyloid plaques
already existing here the most
interesting parameters for the analysis
are the black growth rates in order to
measure if the black roof holds or even
reverses by the therapy with this very
last slide I want to acknowledge some
people first our boss John Holmes who
for all his support and giving us the
opportunity to do this studies and of
course i won't also thank all our lab
numbers what you see on the left picture
and i want to thank all collaborators
bora schmidt and danny akiza who
provided us with meat with the am not
binding agent the toxic 04 and on the
right side you see our new new building
where we are located since last november
and of course i want also to thank all
or all people who are interested in our
seminar and i want to also thank the
organizers from lab fruits and from
android big plane thank you very much
thank you for the informative
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session I'd like
to remind our audience how to submit
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window will try to answer
as many questions as we can and our
first question is can you perform this
experiment with different than
two-photon microscopy setting
well to to perform this experiment well
it's necessary to use two-photon
microscopy in order to image the plaque
growth kinetics in living animals over
time because it gives the best contrast
and has the best penetration depth
compared to two for example confocal
microscopy and of course one could think
about different in vivo imaging
techniques like for example
acousto-optic imaging or or other in
vivo imaging techniques that would be
definitely possible or maybe also pet
imaging and micro PET imaging and which
is also also already used with altima
mouse models to translate data from
mouse models to to to the humans can you
offer measure calc apology with this
message ends up in maybes so this is
actually a question of office stain in
this case so the methoxy XO for is a
very good stain it's very bright and you
can get it you can very well detective
so to my knowledge so the towel is not
really well stainable in vivo and
recordable in vivo but we have um we're
testing for example FSB which seems to
work out have you used this two-photon
microscopy to test any therapeutic
molecule
f we already did so 11 study is already
published dairy tested an antibody or
two different antibodies but they were
not able to to decrease or yeah to to
change the hamlet pathology in this
mouse model and yeah well we also to
test from some other molecules but this
is not yet published and not yet
finished so far yeah i think what area
of the brain are you looking at and do
you see new regional differences in
plaque formation based on ages so the
first question so we are working with
always in the barrel cortex and the
second question I didn't really get what
was it okay what area of the brain are
you looking at and do you see any
regional differences and platforming and
based on ages the age of death of the
person well the so normally really look
and it's almost so my toes on the
sensory cortex and of course the there
is a difference between when you look at
different ages and in the mouse or in
the mouse model and there is there is
also a difference and and the amulet
load or the black identity for example
in different brain regions but this
depends on on the mouse models you will
use so some mouse models have a stronger
plaque pathology and some some less yeah
but overall your variation is quite high
sorry
do you have a behavioral data for your
minds to correlate crack growth with
cognitive decline well so far we haven't
done this kind of experiment so we have
don't have correlation to behavioral
data no next question is a bit of a
two-parter can we eradicate the
formation of the plaques with help of
medications and also before it
progresses to Alzheimer's no so this is
not possible there's no way okay um what
is the what is a half-life of your full
or a fluorescent probe with the mouth
and how much is getting into the brain
well actually this is a three-parter so
you'll see how you want to answer it
first part is what is a half-life of
your full of fluorescent probe in mouth
how much is getting into the brain and
if it commercially available so
sputtering first half question and yes
it is commercially available and the
half-life is quite short so it's it
enters the praying very fast there is
already a publication out from fine
basky from Harvard University who
studied this and so the plane is also
cleared quite fast from this agent but
the diet self sticks very strongly to
the amyloid plaques so once you stay in
the am a plaques with this with this
diet so I've never seen that it
disappears again so you also see it
afterwards when you fix your plane or
profuse your brain and and remove the
brain and make slices so you still see
it okay and gives you to press the part
of it is available commercially I'm
sorry
you can connect yes it is commercially
available I cannot tell you the company
right now because we got it from our
collaborators but i think it's
commercially an label i think your
company from the US in which this is
another two-parter in which brain
regions can you measure plaques and do
you reach the hippocampus well we are
restricted to the areas that we can
reach with the two-photon microscope so
we have a limited penetration depth well
theoretically about 800 micrometer
practically for for this long term
imaging experiments we look normally at
300 to 400 micrometer deaths from the
plane surface and there we can look at
the frontal cortex the visual cortex
somewhat eccentric sensory cortex to all
upper parts of the brain and the
hippocampus we didn't reach so far and
we didn't write actually well there are
some other in vivo studies out out there
now they I use a different kind of
technique to reach the hippocampus and
that be able to vote on imaging there
and actually with this technique it
might be possible but it involves the
removing of part of the of the cortex
above the hippocampus oh it's a bit more
invasive I would say is it possible to
trace intracellular abeka
for at least with this technique we are
using we would need die that would stain
our intracellular a betta and actually
with methoxy we we don't know exactly if
it really penetrate through the cell
membrane but there is this other die
it's called FSB it stains both towel
aggregates and and and also a beta
aggregates so plugs maybe with this one
it might be possible but it's also
difficult to distinguish then some
autofluorescence signals from inside the
cell and and the diet so I would say
it's quite challenging to to Titus can't
got another two parter for you do you
see vascular deposition of amyloid and
it's so this is happening regional
dependence so in the chi Chi 25 676
mouse model that we used the data that
we have shown you we see the rescue our
deficit so the cerebral angio puffy and
we can also stay in them with the most
America see and I cannot or I haven't
investigated really quantitatively if
this is really regional so what I've
seen is that it's mostly on the upper
platform so phase plot was of the very
big ones but it's also develops fur for
it goes further along this level so if
you first see 11 episode appearing at
the plat vessel it will go along to
complete what platteville later on so
there is also
dick taking place yeah you see any
evidence for the hypothetical sink
effect I amyloid deposition sorry can
you repeat the question sure you see any
evidence for the hypothetical sink
effect for amyloid deposition sorry I
didn't get the middle part of what
interested I here ok this is yen telling
mr. than Shawn move to the next one yeah
sure sure do all of your transgenic mice
display the cerebral amyloid angiopathy
phenotype
can you yes so then the TT 2576 mouse
model I think we always see it but we
are testing also other mice for example
malls from the local app which actually
doesn't does not show any angle [ __ ] so
yes it's dependent on the transgenic
mouse model and the next one also has a
few parts so let me know if you want
your key can you explain the Swedish
mutation again is it similar to the ad
42 mediated neurodegeneration and is it
available in gross Julia load of Swedish
mutation is a mutation that is related
to to the Podesta crew tasty which side
and leads to an increased production of
the a pita peptide and the length of the
AP de peptide so because it's dependent
on the gamma secretase or not on the
beta secretase or the Swedish mutation
leads to to an overall increase in the
apt peptide and of course the a pita for
the tool is a bit longer than the other
a bit of 40 the mostly appearing length
of this peptide and but this is not not
changed by this mutation so this is
normally changed by mutations and the
gamma secretase complex and if it
available in droves kalia in where Rosa
furia fila just a million to little vida
oh yeah I don't know if there is a model
and torso feelin sorry okay I looks like
we have time perhaps for one more
question what is the resolution of
two-photon technique
well x and y direction at about 0.3 24
micrometers and in that direction about
1 1 micrometer to one half to two
depending on the optical settings and
the microscope itself ok well that
concludes our question-and-answer period
i would like to thank our sponsored bit
plane for making today's educational
webcast possible today's webcast were
available for on-demand viewing through
December 2015 you'll receive an email
from lab roots alerting you in this
webcast will be available for replay and
we invite you to afford that
announcement to your colleagues we have
missed today's live event the recording
of this lecture and information about
the upcoming webinars any search series
will also be available on bit plane calm
/ search see you next time bye